president biden appeared to get rattled
for about 30 seconds there after losing
his mask
at an outdoor rally in georgia
this despite him being fully vaccinated
he's also pledging to keep wearing a
mask
outside even though his own cdc
tells the rest of the country all of us
upstages him
this week in a press conference of her
own the cdc director
to tell us that we don't have to wear
masks outside any longer if we've been
vaccinated
it's a small precaution to take
that has a profound impact it's a
patriotic responsibility for god's sake
kaley it's a patriotic responsibility to
go against your own cdc maybe that's why
dr
wilinski popped up out of nowhere last
this week and went
first and upstaged the president
yeah that's right i mean it's incredible
he is waging the biggest
vaccine hesitancy campaign in history
he's having a panic attack on stage yeah
a panic attack
on stage because he can't find his mask
going against as you know his own cdc
director
and in that clip you just played just
previous to that portion
of the sound bite he said to craig
melvin hey
i know we're both vaccinated right now
we're socially distanced but even though
we're both vaccinated if we weren't
socially distanced we would be wearing
masks
what clue does that tell america even
when we are all vaccinated
in joe biden's america the mask is here
to stay for no scientific reason
i don't know if people are going to
continue to listen to him on this issue
if his words don't match his actions
uh buck
well look for biden this is now this is
now the
pseudo-religious significance almost of
of mask wearing as being a good
person this is what the ver this is
virtue signaling it's what people that
listen to the science do all along when
actually if you look at the data
the risk for unvaccinated people outside
when it comes to transmission
is very low in fact fauci described it
as minuscule about a week ago
so what do we have here the lab coat
tyrants at the cdc who have gotten
things wrong time and time again
have finally ratcheted it back a little
bit but the democrat hysteria is such
that
they only listen to the science they
like when they like it
and you see this with bi and you'll see
this with a lot maybe we can get him one
of those chains you put your reading
glasses on except for his mask you know
what i mean so that way he won't lose
they have those on amazon
they do i'm sure i'm sure they do you
know they have everything on amazon
so emily look we we don't want to get
too ticky tack here
but does he realize that he's talking
people out of getting the vaccine i mean
is this
is this anti-trump hate behavior on his
part or is it something else
because you know former president trump
did the operation warp speed deals that
brought this on through with the
vaccination is this biden's way of
pushing against the president the former
one and if you really intended to do
that
should he have gone and gotten his
vaccine in december
i think at a minimum it's sending that
message from those in his inner circle
whose messages he himself puppets
and look i feel for the guy for looking
around i've been that guy that has been
looking for my glasses and it's been on
my face or
things like that but it's really
undercutting that message of the vaccine
efficacy
really in a fundamental way and i'm not
quite sure why no one in his circle has
pointed out that if he's outside and
doesn't wear a mask that that is the
largest
symbol supporting the vaccine efficacy
that he can do
and as our commander-in-chief i hope he
sees that light despite
all of the messages he's been uh told by
his inner circle clearly or the rest of
the party
i hope he comes through and realizes
that for himself
it's a great point maybe they are
telling him and you know you don't want
anybody to rest the power
of the pulpit from your hands when
that's the issue that ushered you into
office
so maybe he just doesn't want to give it
up